moi ce qui me crispe c'est la société
victimaire je voilà et je notamment le
féminisme victimaire moi je suis
féministe j'ai grandi comme ça avec une
mère qui travaillait qui était
professeur et je crois que ma vie
montrait que j'exerçais ma liberté ma
volonté d'incarner quelque chose et de
me réaliser donc et de vivre libre je ne
me sens pas victime moi je me sens
maîtresse de mon destin et de ma
position et complètement à l'égale des
hommes donc je le comprends c'est une
réaction sûrement générationnelle ce
n'est pas ma génération donc je peux la
comprendre le problème des violences
faites aux femmes est un vrai problème
je ne le minimise pas et évidemment des
dangers qui les guettent et notamment
évidemment le viol pour ces femmes qui
n'ont aucun moyen de se défendre et
c'est une cause essentielle en revanche
dans nos milieux nos milieux privilégiés
entre guillemets
j'estime que une femme peut se défendre
voilà et moi j'ai toujours je crois
réussi à me défendre la preuve puisque
vous avez été l'une des premières femmes
très exposée à la télévision et au
moment où il y avait beaucoup de
testostérone à la télévision aussi il
faut être la première on se battait
contre des femmes qui étaient des
concurrentes contre des hommes qui
étaient aussi des concurrents mais dans
le journalisme je crois que on peut
témoigner du fait que les femmes ont
toute leur place
[Musique]